frédéric bonsoir alors justement ces
coûts d'organisation des jeux ça fait
reculer beaucoup de villes
oui effectivement on fait les calculs
quand on voit le dossier qui
s'amoncellent on se rend compte
finalement ce n'est peut-être pas
forcément une très très bonne idée juste
d'un epic on parle de 2026 justement
mais avant calgary il ya la ville de
sapporo au japon il ya la suisse et
l'autriche qui ont également retiré
leurs billes bien avant de savoir s'il
allait être sélectionné pour
l'organisation même chose également en
2024 là c'était au tour de l'italie
autour de la bulle de la hongrie et
l'allemagne de retirer leur candidature
et vous le voyez comme ça plusieurs
années année après année on voit des
petits candidats là qui décident de
complètement se mettre en dehors du jeu
on voit quand même une tendance c'est
que plus les années passent et plus il y
en a qui se retire même avant de savoir
ce qui va arriver
évidemment c'est l'argent bien sûr c'est
les dépenses qui font peur à civile et à
ces pays et aussi des consultations
publiques et des référendums qui sont
organisés il a les gens disent non on ne
veut rien savoir de ces jeux olympiques
c'est pas un phénomène nouveau en fait
si on se rappelle denver au colorado en
1976 il avait obtenu l'organisation des
jeux olympiques et là malheureusement
pour eux il ya eu un référendum et il
était décidé par référendum qu'on ne
pouvait pas engager des fonds publics
pour dépenser et pour organiser les jeux
donc ils ont dû céder leur place et
donner la chance à l'autriche cette
année là en tout cas préféré que le
passage des jeux a laissé des traces
financière là dans certaines villes
organisatrices
oui parce qu'il ya des choses qui
coûtent très cher d'abord c'est le
fameux dépôt de candidature donc
organiser à tout un dossier
ça coûte entre 50 et 150 millions de
dollars sans même savoir si vous allez
remporter ces organisations et puis bien
sûr on parle évidemment des coûts de
construction qui sont parfois
astronomiques à ce propos là on va
passer en vue justement les dépassements
de coûts de certaines certaines villes
on va commencer par un des moins pire
regarder barcelone 1992 266% ensuite
bessam anti le hammer en norvège 277 la
liste continue sotchi-2014 289 lake
placid à new york c'était 324 et le pire
c'est le grand trou ici 1
c'est le fameux stade olympique montréal
1976 720% de dépassement du coup c'est
astronomiques
et oui ça fait mal effectivement mais
évidemment ce sont les pires exemples
mais il ya certaines villes qui ont
réussi à
rennes leur épingle du jeu mais oui los
angeles curieusement 1932 qui a fait de
l'argent en fait pour la première fois
de l'histoire des jeux olympiques à un
million de dollars de profits et
figurez-vous que quelques années plus
tard en 1984 rebelote encore une fois et
cette fois ci ils ont engrangé pas moins
de 250 millions de dollars et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que en 2028 vu que los
angeles est la seule ville qui a proposé
sa candidature elle risque de pouvoir
bien négocié avec le comité olympique
international
merci beaucoup frédéric eloire